hello and welcome to this video playing
my way yeah I really want to find out
what he does against its opening as
again never tried it against Americans
probably six I'm probably not the wisest
choice against him my name is a good
attacking player Air Force
surprising normally why tries to play
with the pieces there and H form let's
see
I sometimes wish I would be so easygoing
Alec that negative never work I mean
really it's absolutely clear that this
does not work but okay it's like be
relaxed in blitz you can play all kinds
of crap okay so I take the center pawn
now with what excellent exactly I'm not
saying I'm winning I mean this is just
just just going to be some some Becky
game as usual
is that I could never do that like it
it's just not didn t even see that he
falls hanging that's possible so it can
happen so probably Bishop d3m something
something like that
nope
so at least here I know my move yeah I
think I have to go back and be be ready
to take on c3
so short castles is a pretty cool move
here
Olga vada I don't know
I mean f5 is what idea is completely
busted really completely but will still
be wacky and so here I am just this one
494 I also want to get the get long
castles on the way 26:57 castles long
so just Bishop d7 or I mean this one the
ambition of this heaven looks easy em
there might be stuff already that kills
me totally like g5 or a5 but I don't I
don't want that just I mean the position
should be completely winning if I just
knock blunder stuff 85 especially no
strong okay so e5
so just c6 or d4 I can go d4 actually
there's nothing wrong with it or take or
take I mean everything is good in some
way
come on let's let's just not cover D 5
keep the big Center and then see what
happens
the only thing that irritates me
slightly is before when a seven is
hanging in 96
is the kind of thing where ever an
engine gives like minus three but you
still have to play it I mean in some
cases you might might play some some
something stupid and things all the
sudden turn out to be the a tricky
Mays taking a long time I will play e5
or almost no matter what
now I'm still connected okay except so I
think I'll take okay so p.m. what is the
idea
only this one 494
a magic f5 I should trade the Queen
quite realize okay I don't I don't think
that I don't think this it this works in
this way maybe six a certain year move
but I have my doubts about f1 h for the
combination of those two most you know
we just gave ready for like instantly I
just I just don't believe it
well the engine is instantly saying it
basically loses but yeah again playing
training it as a different matter
yeah so yeah look a fade immediately
probably was better with eclipse very
very convincing
I get long Casselton 57 five you're
taking immediately was that I am I
wasn't entirely sure that's something
something something we adhere in the
action c6 also defy us
to that default was already better yeah
I just I just need to avoid blundering
something and then then I'm winning this
easily yeah I think it was reasonably
okay you could have found one quicker or
in a more incisive way but as long as
you don't allow some some swindle
everything's good okay guys thanks for
watching